[Musique]
aujourd'hui je vais vous présenter les
poissons d'Antona de Christine via et
Céline de Ren courour chez Epsilon
jeunesse
dans l'histoire d'Antonin nous avions vu
un banc
d'apogons les apogons ce sont des petits
poissons qui vivent en groupe dans les
correaux on peut les voir dès l'entrée
de l'eau à l'âge adulte ils sont grands
comme ta
main il y avait également la carangue
bleue ce poisson est un peu farouche il
ignore la présence des plongeurs on le R
rencontre près des massifs chaliens
quand il est grand il est presque aussi
grand que
toi le poisson chirurgien c'est celui
qui faisait un
festin ce poisson vit dans les lagons il
nage lentement mais se cache à la
moindre
alerte adulte il est aussi grand qu'une
feuille de papier souviens-toi il y
avait aussi le poisson
épervier presque aussi grand que ton
pied il vit près des correaux et peut
rester longtemps sans bouger surtout
quand il
chasse et l'ange empereur le bel ange
empereur ce poisson se laisse facilement
approcher lorsqu'il est jeune il est
recouvert d'anneaux blancs et quand il
grandit les anneaux deviennent des
lignes
bleu et enfin il y avait le corail c'est
un petit animal des mers chaudes vivant
en colonie son squelettees lorsqu'ils
sont plusieurs forment le récif coralien
l'aspect des Correau rappelle celui des
[Musique]
plantes